The Joe Rogan experience. So I mean, yeah,
I'm with you in that I am
ridiculously optimistic.
Oh that's good. I think that
I think people, I mean I'm,
I follow Steven Pinker's logic of that.
People will sort of look at the horrible
things that we have today and say,
God, this world is terrible. Now.
There are definitely terrible aspects,
but this is without doubt the greatest
time ever to be alive that we've ever
seen, at least in recorded human
history. I would agree with that.
I think communication
is a giant part of that.
It is.
This is this global a world which we
thought was going to be beautiful thing.
And then people said, oh no,
it's a hellish thing. In fact,
it's got beautiful aspects and some
hellish aspects as any invention has.
You know, like Internet, hey, you can
teach someone how to save their life on,
on the Internet. Ah, you can also teach
online and make a bomb on the incident,
you know? So I think this is always
there. Every next step we get,
we will have some positives.
Then we'll hit all the negatives and
then we'll go back to small positive.
So yeah, I've, I've got to be able to miss
it. Yeah. Well I am an optimistic person.
I otherwise it just wouldn't be here.
But this military aspect that I mentioned,
I'm flipping back to that. But yeah,
I do try and think I need to do this.
I think that's a good thing to do. Now.
I need to do that. If a 10, nine years,
I've been saying I'm going to politics,
so I'm going next year,
but it might not be a general election.
I try and plan ahead because I can't,
I can't if I randomized it,
like just float because a lot of people
do find out this happened and then that
happened. And then I was like, and
that could be a wonderful life,
but I have my river analogy. If
you're canoeing down the river, um,
if you go at the same speed as the river,
they could throw you under rocks.
He could give you a wonderful ride.
It could be anything,
but it's up to the river.
Whereas I pedal like crazy.
Sometimes I back pedal like crazy.
I have actively backpedaled
against things and,
and sometimes usually I'm peddling faster
than the speed of the river to try and
guide myself through. You see that
whenever do these canoeing. Um,
well anyone driving a boat through
the river and when I looked look
at human interactions objectively,
part of me has to consider that there's
a possibility that we need all this
negative in order to reinforce the
positive that there is some component of
human life that desires or,
or relies upon negative
things to reinforce positive
things that this yin and
Yang that we, we exist
under that, this, this,
that we see the horrors of war and
horrific poverty and all these terrible
things in the horrible violence.
We see this and it actually serves to
reinforce our desire for positive things
and reinforce and push our society in
a more positive direction. I mean, I'm,
I almost think that this is when we see
national tragedies and shootings and all
these different, terrible,
terrible things, there's,
there's all this fear and
anger and frustration,
but there's also action and the action
might meet new might think there's a lack
of action by politicians are a lack of
action by the police or a lack of action
by,
you know,
whoever we think should be responsible
for mitigating these horrible situations
that happen. But publicly, the, the,
the, the social fabric of the world,
the way people communicate and interact,
I think it reinforces our
desire to not have that happen.
It reinforces our understanding
of peace and our love of peace.
And I think that these,
these bad things that we see in our world,
they're almost propel us towards a
better world because human beings are
constantly striving for
improvement and innovation.
This is one of the things that we do.
We want things to be better and
bigger and faster and stronger.
And we want our society to be better at
all times. We never say this is good.
Let's keep it just the way it is.
We never, we never say that. So my,
my thought is that even this, even what
we were experiencing in this country,
we like,
it seems at times that were almost like
on the brink of civil war between the
right and the left and people align
on both sides and conflating people's
opinions and changing people's
perspectives in order to
suit their own narrative
that I think that this ultimately all
this [inaudible] you see it from the
outside and you look at and go,
what the fuck are we doing?
I think it's a natural part of the
way human beings figure out life.
I shall respond to, sure. Yeah. I,
I think, I think almost the same as you.
I would not take it slightly differently.
I've noticed that humanity only sometimes
gets going and does things when he's
right up against the wall. You know,
somebody that needs these things to go on.
If you took a wellbore to scenario.
We went right to the wire on that and
then suddenly we came back and maybe not
even, it wasn't even the political
will on that. It was just actually,
if the Japanese haven't bombed
Pearl Harbor, we wouldn't you guys,
we wouldn't have had you guys
in us with us for a DNA to, yes,
all that. All the, the,
the forces and the,
the money and the almond and the tanks
and the shermans coming in. You know,
we needed that coming in and without
the Russian people we wouldn't have won
world war two and that was,
and they were in this agreement.
So I can't quite work out humanity. I do
think positive. I do think the negatives,
you can appreciate the positives more.
I do think one thing on, on the Brexit,
Brexit hate thing that's been going on,
there's a lot of young people
are coming on and saying, well,
so we're going to lose all this stuff.
The ability we could travel to to
Europe without visas. We can work there,
we could retire there,
we can get a healthcare.
They're all costs you and that's going
to tell you we cut off and we are roaming
charges are going to go out with the old
that people are valuing what they, uh,
they could lose a lot more.
So yeah, the Yin and Yang,
the you can, I think, I think
it's gonna go on this way.
And also some people once,
once we get to a good place,
I've noticed that a lot
of people will say, okay,
I'm not going to be
politically active anymore.
I'm just going to carry on doing my life
and getting other people can sort of
things that I've noticed that people
will get activated to get to a result.
Maybe an election result, something
or a referendum or whatever it is.
And then they'll, they will just
back off. They get frustrated,
they get faster or they just
think, well, that's done.
That's bagged and in a positive way maybe.
And just say,
but now I'm not even gonna pay
attention to what's going on,
but things will start
rolling backwards. So, um,
I think we're going to
keep having it like that.
Maybe the but the percentage of
positive things to negative things.
It's never changed over all the years.
Over the last 10,000 years.
It's just there's more people in the
world doing more positive things and doing
well and negative things.
Maybe humanity hasn't changed cause
I brain sizes haven't changed.
Even back to the cavemen days,
you know,
even back for the last
hundred thousand years,
the size of our brains is not moved.
So we,
if you went back to
seven 70,000 years ago,
we would still be able to
have conversations like
this even though we wouldn't
have the radios and things.
It'd be more on our tribe.
I think I'll try B is better than you
are trying to say. Actually Steve,
I don't know if our tribe
is better than that tribe.
I just think liberals are similar than
some good people that drive in this same
shit as in that drive.
We need to maybe trade with them
or we can go to war with them,
but then we could die
lot and Shelly could die.
And Kenny and Roger and number 22,
you know,
because those conversations were
happening in this slightly different way I
think all the way back. And it wasn't
all just bring me food. You Nice,
good three fight. It wasn't that, it was
maybe, you know, millions of years ago,
but not 700,000 years ago.
And we only started speaking
a hundred thousand years ago.
What we've developed since
then, I'm fascinated by us
as human beings because we,
we, uh, we were just another
animal and now we are,
we are kind of amazing animal.
We've fermented beautifully.
We landed on the bloody moon.
You guys landed on the moon,
which I as a child thought that we
landed on the moon, but in fact you guys,
I did them, but they, they Apollo
11, they kept it quite open.
I think Michael Collins in the command
module. So this is for the world.
And there was this kind of feeling. And
Neil Armstrong is, it's a nice, yeah,
I grabbed hold of that as a kid. I was
growing up, you know, but younger than me.
But it's pretty weird thing to think that
we went from not being able to talk to
space travel in a hundred thousand years.
I mean, that's what they think, right?
They think that people didn't have real
language. 100,000 folks be two genetic.
Um, I think it's about a hundred thousand
years ago. That's when it came to,
and the first words we said was,
let's go to the moon in 100,000.
What's your name? Jack
Kennedy. Okay. Jack. Good idea.
But let's put it on the
back burner for the moment.
What do you think happened
that turned us into this?
Do you ever stop and think about that?
Well,
I don't think it's a bloke
upstairs floating in the
clouds because they used to
live in the clouds and then we flew
through the clouds and no one ever had
mentioned, hey, he's not in the cloud.
So I, it's a randomized thing, you know,
I think these random like dinosaurs
hundred and 65 million years of those
bastards, right? And all
they did was eight, uh,
kill eight cold pool and, and
have sex. That's all they did.
Those four things for 165 million years,
we've had 300 years since
the enlightenment of human
rights and democracy and
stuff like that. If we, if we say
the Great Greeks did a great thing,
but it really is lost, we're going to do
is they had 165 million years of that.
But why did they come along when we
had all these creatures in the sea and
suddenly huge ones, something
happened, something twisted,
randomizing thing. It's,
I, I, we, we, I know.
Maybe we'll never know,
but it has happened and I just don't
think a bloke did it upstairs with a big
beard.
He said,
now is the time that you speak and now
you make handbags and now fight wars with
the MG 42 bow. Now, you know,
I just,
I just think it happened and we need
to roll with it and try and make humans
work on this planet, because then
we're going to be going a mile soon.
And you can just say it the future,
if we got it going on Mars at some,
but the margins, because we want to vote,
we've got our own Martian government.
You sure you earthlings, you know, they're
going to treat us the same way. Yeah.
Ricans treat the British. Yeah. And
then the has come back and attack us.
The [inaudible] you could just see
that in some sort of, you know,
how did you turn the light? Sure. Yeah.
Definitely happy. You know, and I,
so I, I, I despair about
humanity and I, and I,
and I, I celebrate humanity. Yeah.